hi my name is Sandeep Gupta and I'm the
product manager of tensorflow JavaScript
today I'm really excited to talk to you
at the chrome developer summit about
machine learning in JavaScript as a web
developer you may have felt that all
this buzz and excitement about machine
learning seems to require Python and how
you as a JavaScript developer can jump
in and use machine learning I want to
show you that now machine learning in
JavaScript is real powerful and useful
and you can do some amazing things with
it earlier this year Google released its
first ever a I powered google doodle in
this users could synthesize a box style
harmony using a machine learning model
running directly in their browser so in
only three days more than 50 million
people use this doodle to create save
and share their music a creative
marketing team in Google has built a fun
interactive experience where users are
shown a zodiac symbol and they try to
match the shown animal with a shadow of
their hand making that character come to
life other teams are experimenting with
novel ways of making web interfaces more
accessible in this example here on the
bottom left called create ability people
can control web interfaces with gesture
such as playing a keyboard with their
face motion all of these amazing
examples have been made possible by tens
of loggias tensorflow jeaious is an open
source library for machine learning in
JavaScript it runs in a web browser
and can also be used server-side and on
many other platforms that support
JavaScript you can use tensorflow
javascript in one of three different
ways you can run a pre trained machine
learning model in your application you
can customize a pre trained model by
retraining it on your own data or you
can use the lower-level
ops API to write a new model from
scratch directly in JavaScript there are
many reasons why you may want to
consider using tensorflow JavaScript
first of all it allows web application
developers and JavaScript developers to
use machine learning directly in their
applications and it's really easy to get
started and be up and running with only
a few lines of code
you can load our library and you can
load a pre trained model such as the
body picks model and this is a
model that allows you to do person
segmentation on an image you create an
instance of the model and then you call
its estimate person segmentation method
on your selected image and you get back
a JSON object which contains the
segmentation mask which can then be
directly used in your application code
that's all there is to it so in just a
couple minutes you are up and running
and you're using ml in your web
application without having to deal with
concepts such as tensors optimizers
losses etc tensorflow J s can be used
client-side in the browser and other
browser like platforms this has many
advantages you get all the benefits of
the interactivity of web as a platform
and users can use directly microphones
and webcams and other sensors that are
attached to the browser users don't need
to install anything so your application
becomes instantly deployable and
shareable another big benefit is that
user data stays client-side and this has
very big implications for privacy for
applications such as healthcare for
example and it also helps reduce latency
and server side costs finally we support
GPU acceleration through WebGL which
gives it excellent performance out of
the box although in this talk we are
mainly talking about browser use cases I
should mention that tensorflow J's can
also be used with node.js server side
and this is very useful for enterprise
applications when node is heavily used
so a natural question to ask is how fast
is it where it turns out it's really
fast for example on mobile devices
running inference with an image
classification example using the mobile
network model you get real-time
performance with 20 milliseconds
inference time and on server side we
have performance parity with Python
based tensor flows so to help you get
started we have a collection of pre
trained ml models for common ml problems
that we have prepackaged for you these
include use cases such as image
classification and object detection
detecting human pose and gesture audio
models for recognizing spoken words and
building speech command interfaces and
text models for text classification
sentiment analysis toxicity detection
etc it's really easy to use any of these
we train models with our high-level rapt
api's from our hosted scripts or you
could install from our NPM packages
using these models as building blocks
applications can be built for a variety
of use cases these include things like
accessibility they are VR experiences
such as virtual product try ons
conversational agents and moderating
user generated content on your web sites
so these pre trained models are a great
starting point often however in real
life you need to customize these models
on your own data so one way to do this
is again by using the power of
tensorflow running directly in the
browser interactively and using that to
train a model on your own data let's
take a look at how easy this is so in
this demo I will show you how to use
teachable Machine to train a custom
model so the mobile net image
classification model is already running
in this browser session and we will
modify it to recognize symbols for rock
paper and scissors so we're going to
output the word rock for the first class
we will output the word paper for the
second class and will output scissors
for the third class now let's record the
training images for these three classes
so first let's take our images for rock
so I'll hold up my hand like this rock
and now let's record some images for
paper and now let's record some images
for scissors paper
scissors and now that model is ready for
inference let's take a look rock paper
scissors paper rock paper scissors so
that's all there is to it in a few
minutes you have a custom model trained
in the browser so so far we have seen
the capabilities of the library now
let's take a look at some use cases
Mada face is an augmented reality
technology company based in Canada and
they have used tensorflow J s in the V
chat mini program platform to build a
beauty product virtual Tryon application
for L'Oreal using tensorflow Jas they
were able to deploy a custom model
meeting their model size and speed
constraints for this application and you
can do the same thing in browser
extensions to showcase how you can
enable amazing user experiences with the
power of tensor flow GS we have built an
application here we are running a state
of the art machine learning model to
track users lips and face movement and
we use that to lip-sync to a song and
score how well you do you get awesome
real-time performance that enables this
application and because there are many
JavaScript visualization libraries out
there we can use them to add on some
cool special effects so let's take a
look
[Music]
companies are using tensorflow jeaious
for a variety of purposes whether it be
for internal tools for experimentation
and visualization at uber
privacy-preserving client-side
application at Airbnb and also offline
mobile device use case for field use by
IBM Research lastly I want to highlight
that the success of the library is due
to our amazing contributor and user
community the library continues to grow
in usage and popularity and we are
really excited about the amazing
libraries that the community is building
on top of tensorflow JS to extend its
functionality and applications so thank
you all this was a quick intro to
tensorflow JS please do check out our
website where we have more demos and
examples and getting started guides and
resources and also from there you can
join our developer mailing list thank
you so much for watching
you